this is a cnbc story when your rent goes
up 40 as pandemic fades
many tenants see big hikes
as a purely discounted rents in cities
comes to an end many tenants are bracing
for steep increases that could force
them to leave their homes as cities
begin to begin to resemble
their pre-cove itself
again and the period of discounted rents
evaporates many tenants are facing a
similarly unpleasant reversal renters
who originally receive pandemic pricing
are now experiencing steep rent
increases at renewal uh sometimes
upwards of 40 so for example if you're
paying four thousand dollars a month
it's going to go to 56 that's a real
number by the way if you're paying two
grand it's gonna go to twenty eight
hundred that eight hundred dollars a car
payment and a cell phone bill and maybe
insurance
uh so said aliyah mohammed ceo of open
igloo which allows renters in new york
uh city to review landlords i'm amazed
this is legal
while it's true that most tenants in the
u.s aren't protected by rent control
policies some are mean while others are
helped by requirements they may be given
a certain amount of resilience okay all
right so forty percent tom what do you
think is going to happen here
i think rents are going up baby because
then i'll give you two reasons is it
inevitable i think it's inevitable
because percent inevitable
i don't think now 40
i think is a good headline it's a big
spike but it's going up if you you
listen to the average joe it's up 15
it's up 20 you're seeing multiple
markets people talking about it and
there's there's a couple issues going on
here number one
we are so fortunate that most of the u.s
counties because counties control the
property taxes not the states individual
counties
do not raise the taxes on a mark to
market basis each year they
incrementally raise them it's like a
small raise on it but when you commit a
transaction
then that's a new super step
in the property tax and what you've got
here is people are buying
rental homes highly leveraged highly
leveraged and so soon as we get interest
rates rising on those underlying
mortgages under the rental house that's
pushing it up and inflation in general
is pushing it up and i think the average
consumer that's renting is is going to
get jammed by this this is just the tip
of the iceberg 40 big headline story but
this is happening okay kai what do you
think uh i mean this is the craziest
number for me is the from 57 in the
second quarter to 74 and third i mean
that's uh what do you mean what do you
mean by that 57-74 attracting qualified
people um he said the
percentage of firms difficult attracting
qualified
uh well i'm on the wrong story what am i
doing here okay
no but the biggest thing biggest thing
for me is in terms of that um i spoke to
sam and for us the place we stayed would
would go up 400 bucks for next year
where you're at right now yeah per month
per month no for the whole year okay so
the whole rent would go up 400 uh and
zero vert 400 per month no 400 total i
believe per year yes what are you
talking about no it's not no no no per
month per month yeah the monthly basis
so that's five grand a year yeah that
adds up you know when when the whole
rent forgiveness thing was happening
yeah couldn't you see this thing is
where was this going to end that lasted
for over a year and you know there was a
lot of landlords that took it in the
shorts in in a huge way but they were
talking about mass
evictions and how i mean if you have any
common sense you would think that would
have to happen so what are the numbers
apparently evictions are up 12 in
september and they're up 25 in october
over august so they're happening but one
of the reasons they're not super
terrible is they had all that federal
money available right that they had a
lot of rental assistance money and i
guess some of that is getting used now i
think i saw where 10 billion is now
being used by about 2 million renters
that have access to it but to use that
money you need the landlord to
participate in that program with you and
i can imagine so many landlords are
ticked off that these renters did not
pay for a year or a year longer longer
than a year and many could and
definitely could and they want them out
regardless right so they're not going to
participate and try to get these federal
funds they're going to get somebody get
them out of there bring somebody in
there they can raise the rent a little
bit so i think this is just the
beginning of this because there are
real-life consequences to not paying
your rent for a year right and rolling
the dice and taking that gamble but
here's the thing so this leads me to the
story of labor shortage okay this is a
cnn story if the labor shortage
continues the u.s economy won't be able
to recover after enhanced unemployment
benefits expired and schools reopen in
person many expected workers to go back
to work in nations labor shortage to
ease significantly by september but
recent data suggests if anything the
shortage is getting more severe a
majority of smaller firms 51 percent say
that they have job openings they are
unable to fill the ceo confidence survey
revealed that the percentage of firms
citing difficulty attracting qualified
people jumped from 57
in q2 of 2021 to
for the first time in decades the
scenario of wage price will spiral where
higher price and rising wages feed each
other by the way you know what the
numbers of how many people
are fewer employed today than it was two
years ago you know the number millions
what is the numbers working workforce
yes i'm gonna say 12 million seven
million fewer today that are not even
going back by the way seven million no
interest and and the seven million
people that we're talking about they're
not buying cars they're going to their
jobs one small thing happens they just
say i don't want to work i go home
and they're not feeling like there's any
major urgency to want to work there is
zero urgency right now to go back to
work seven million that's not a few
that's a lot of people right there we
just we just bought a building right
this one building that we bought and
we're sitting down with a designer
and a designer comes in and the
architect i said so how long is it going
to take to get the permits he says
that's not a problem you're going to get
four to six weeks i said okay great how
long is it going to take for us to get
you know the demo and all the stuff on
the inside he says we'll get a gc we'll
get that done within four to six months
okay fine sounds good weeks six six four
to six uh no no four to six months the
gc that is four is not weeks four to six
months also demo and build what you
desire yes four to six months i said so
what's the biggest challenge he says you
ready i said yes he says do you want
glass doors and glass windows in your
office i said of course he says six to
12 months i said get out of here says
yeah he says are you buying new
furniture or are you bringing furniture
i said no it's going to be a new
furniture because it's a new look with
the designer he says six to 12 months i
said are you kidding me says labor
shortage and supply is adding up we
can't get people to work and we can't
get supplies today
people are being affected by this you
saw the other car company what is the
car company tyler i don't know if we
have that as one the series or not gm gm
is talking about the fact that
the chips are what but i know was
general motors reveals heated seat
option
due to chip shortage they're removing it
what do you mean you're removing it so
the labor shortage the chips this is
being affected in many different
industries yeah you know what i read a
really interesting study preparing for
this story and it came out from the
american institute of economic research
i don't know if they have any political
leanings whatsoever but they said that
this labor shortage is not a surprise to
the government in fact they call it
mandated and subsidized mandated
mandated because of the coveted
shutdowns right you shut down the
economy
this is what's going to happen and they
knew it subsidized means all the free
money that they're giving out so what
they're basically saying is the people
that are making these decisions
are anti-capitalists and it's a fact and
you can look at the data because the
markets correct themselves they have a
way of correcting themselves when it
comes to the labor pool right enough
people will go out there but it's not
like these people have permanently
pulled themselves out of the workforce
they don't want to go back because they
don't have to go back the job is there
you know what they've learned here's
what they've learned in the last year
they don't want to go back to that same
job at the same pay because they know
they can get more or they can make more
doing nothing so the government knows
exactly this is economics 101
for governments and politicians and they
know about this and this is happening
because they wanted to simple question
for you the seven million people that
are not voting today okay
let's just play a simple game do you
think these seven million people what
percentage of them do you think are
going to vote for more you know benefits
more money to be sent out free money are
they going to vote left or what
percentage of 7 million is going to vote
right they're going to vote 90 percent
for where they can keep the gravy train
cut what do you think
out of the 7 million include our friend
sammy one thousand percent they're gonna
vote for
to stay home and not do much so so the
seven million who are not wanting to go
back they're gonna vote for more more of
the same good stimulus checks to be sent
out to them okay then if that's the case
if we're talking purely strategically
it's working great strategy for the
people on the left it's very strategic
because you got seven million more votes
you've got votes and it's a solid number
by the way if you think about it yeah i
feel a little differently i think you
get a dive into these numbers a little
bit because i i read that there was two
and a half million
older people that were in you know
moderately
moderately priced jobs as you don't earn
a lot that kind of
retired a little early that basically
said you know i'm not going to go back
to that i got a little for the
government now i'm about to get social
security those people are very very sick
they're going to vote for the gravy
train but if the gravy train is temporal
right unless it's going to be a
permanent shift to socialism we're just
going to keep printing money and keep
handing it to people which can't happen
right our our structure in the u.s the
u.s economic structure will not sustain
that then ultimately
you know they want you know low crime
they want lower taxes they want lower
inflation and so they're going to swing
that other way i don't think the 7
million are completely uniquely you know
what someone would say you know
liberally minded just to keep voting for
their check a lot of them are but i was
reading about a sliver of these older
people that were sort of retiring early
and are not giving up what has been you
know a conservative value structure
they're just kind of fed up with the you
know the coveted mandates and everything
that went with the job they're like you
know what i'm retiring early yeah i have
so much sympathy and respect for small
business owners what they've had to
endure in the last year and now when
they can finally try to get back and
they can't find workers i can't imagine
anything more frustrating than that than
having these open positions and not
being able to fill them and knowing that
you can't run your business like you
normally would they're the ones they're
really the only ones that are affected
right these small business owners it was
dunkin donuts with the sign on there it
says please be patient with the length
of the line if you really want to
complain about it ask for an application
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]